what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so as we return to our vs. series this
week today we're going to be taking a
look at a matchup that may not seem like
an obvious one to do at first but I
think that it actually makes for a
pretty interesting battle because these
two competitors are so different from
one another today we're gonna pit the
greatest detective of the DC Universe
against Marvel's unstoppable juggernaut
and the reason why I chose this battle
is because these two characters really
exemplify the ultimate battle of brains
and brawn on one hand you have Batman
who has no super powers but defeats all
of his opponents through planning
strategy and technology on the other
hand you have juggernaut a character
who's afforded extreme strength by way
of a mystical artifact and so like
always before we declare a winner we
first have to take a look at each of
these guys now assuming that you've been
part of human civilization for the last
100 years you probably have a pretty
good idea of who Batman is and what he
can do but on the off chance that you're
new to humanity meaning that you're like
an alien or you've just never had a
reason to learn about one of those
popular super heroes of all time please
post a comment down below and tell me if
you've never heard a Batman if you don't
know anything about Batman and if
somebody posts that comment do not give
them a hard time all right
like you'll you'll you'll get in trouble
all right you will you'll be in trouble
and that's it that's not okay but
assuming that you never had time to
learn about that man we'll take a few
minutes and run down exactly what it is
that he can do so Batman is a pretty
formidable fighter
I mean he's highly skilled in
hand-to-hand combat and he's an expert
martial artist and he's actually been
trained in about 127 forms of martial
arts now this training paired with his
peak physical condition make Batman one
of the most elite fighters in the DC
Universe even more important in this
however is this almost inexhaustible
wealth and the reason why I say this is
that it's Batman's well that allows him
to develop and acquire all the
technology that makes Batman able to be
a superhero like his body armor the
Batmobile the batwing and all the other
gadgets that he uses to fight
supervillains in addition to this he has
an extensive computer system in the
Batcave that allows him to do basically
anything he needs to do in order to gain
an advantage over his opponents now
having gone over Batman
we'll turn our attention to the
juggernaut who I think it means a like a
little more of an explanation because
you'd have to be a crazy person to
believe that the juggernaut is as
well-known as Batman I don't mean to
call you crazy the idea is crazy
anyway the juggernaut draws his power
from an object known as the Crimson gem
of cyttorak which is quite literally a
gem that bestows immense strength and
durability on the person who wields it
by channeling the Crimson energy of the
demons in Iraq in the Crimson dimension
not as the avatar of said Iraq
juggernaut possesses superhuman strength
to the extent that he's been able to
break mountains apart like he did in
Hope number 172 he can lift buildings
out of the ground and use them as
weapons like he did an uncanny x-men
number 361 the juggernauts durability
also allows him to withstand a great
deal of physical damage and in addition
to this he's able to use the gems energy
to generate a force field that renders
him immune to basically any physical
attack even from characters as strong as
Thor which the juggernaut did in Thor
number 429 when he was able to withstand
a direct impact from Mjolnir now in
addition to this ability to absorb
damage a juggernaut is able to survive
without air food or water and does not
suffer physical fatigue meaning that in
addition to his almost instantaneous
healing factor once the juggernaut
begins moving it's almost physically
impossible to stop him however what
apparent weakness of the juggernaut is
psychic attacks while his helmet did
protect him from such attacks there have
been instances when his helmet was
removed leaving him vulnerable once
again however this weakness appears to
have been retcon initiative a19 of the
second volume of amazing x-men when Cain
Marko was once again given the power of
CID Iraq after spending years without it
now that being said we have to answer
the question who would win Batman or
juggernaut well first and foremost I
think it's pretty obvious that if both
of these characters met one another for
the first time and engaged in battle
juggernaut would score pretty decisive
victory I mean Batman would simply have
no way of inflicting any damage on
juggernaut in any form whatsoever and so
his proficiency as a fighter would be
virtually irrelevant and wouldn't really
do him any good however I can hear I can
hear it right now I don't care how far
away you are I can hear I can hear the
voices right now raha
what about prep time of course you can't
expect Batman to defeat juggernaut
sight-unseen
but if you give them time to prepare
Batman can defeat anyone and honestly
this actually raises a pretty
interesting point a lot of fans really
do hold the opinion that because Batman
has basically infinite resources as well
as the intellect to figure out his
opponent's weaknesses
now there's pretty much no one Batman
cannot defeat given adequate time to
scout his opponent and develop a plan to
beat them and now the reason this is
interesting however is because I don't
think Batman has ever faced an opponent
quite like the juggernaut certainly
there isn't anyone in Batman's rogues
gallery that can compare to juggernaut
in terms of physical strength we've seen
Bane give Batman significant trouble
even to the point of breaking his back
but we haven't seen anything in comics
to suggest that Bane is anywhere near
juggernauts level of strength and while
his true Batman has taken down Superman
that's always been because Batman knows
Superman's biggest weakness which is
kryptonite and it's found ways to use it
against him with juggernaut however
things are not so easy as we discussed
earlier juggernauts biggest weakness is
telepathic attacks which has been
retconned out of existence but even if
we put that to the side is pretty much
impossible for Batman to exploit this
weakness anyway while kryptonite may be
rare someone with Batman's wealth and
connections will be able to acquire it
without too much difficulty to say
nothing of the fact that he can
synthesize it like he did in Tower of
Babel what would prove difficult however
would be for Batman to exploit
juggernauts weakness of telepathy seeing
his Batman is not a telepath and has no
way of becoming one although I don't
know I want to see a story where Batman
becomes a telepath but with that in mind
in order to defeat juggernaut Batman is
going to have to find a way to go
toe-to-toe with juggernaut physically
now Batman definitely has ways of making
himself physically stronger there have
been instances where Batman's done this
usually by outfitting himself with a
suit of mechanized armor we've actually
seen Batman have a suit that is so
durable that he's been able to defeat
the rest of the Justice League while
wearing it during the in-game art of
scott Snyder's Batman run now this is
yet another example in support of the
fact that Batman can be a formidable foe
for anyone with adequate time to prepare
since he obviously would be no match for
the Justice League from a purely
physical standpoint and so it's at least
theoretically possible for Batman to
such an Armour to make up for his
physical disadvantage in this battle
with the juggernaut however there are
some important distinctions that we need
to focus on here first
Batman's battle with a Justice League
ends when he subdue Superman using
kryptonite so we don't really know how
long Batman's honor would have held up
against a continued onslaught of punches
from Superman had he not been able to
incapacitate him furthermore we don't
know how long the suit would last
against a similar barrage from
juggernaut but we can infer that sooner
or later juggernaut is going to be able
to get through the suit and he gets if
we continue his attack for an indefinite
amount of time without getting tired
this is kind of interesting because even
Superman suffers fatigue after enough
exertion and so bad and what has to be
able to engineer and even stronger suit
to withstand an attack from juggernaut
that he would need for Superman and
whether or not he's able to do this is
really something that we don't know for
sure but it seems unlikely that Batman
can make something that would be able to
endure an unlimited amount of damage and
so what that means is that for Batman to
win he's actually going to have to find
a way to defeat juggernaut before his
armor gives out and whether he can
actually do that is what this battle
really hinges on and I think that it
actually tips this battle and
juggernauts favor as we discussed before
juggernaut is the avatar of a demon
sidorak and extremely powerful demon
while Batman is extremely intelligent
and has an almost unlimited arsenal of
bleeding edge technology at his disposal
he doesn't really have a way of
neutralizing mystical demonic energy at
least not that I know of and especially
not when the source of the energy comes
from a universe that he's almost
completely unfamiliar with and so for
that reason I think the despite Batman
being able to prolong his survival for a
bit he's not going to be able to harm
juggernaut and can't keep jumping out at
bay forever so in the end we have to
give the win to my man K Marco but with
that being said let me know down in the
comments which side you guys think would
win if you guys are new here to come as
explained hit the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoy
this video drop a like also fair warning
next week I am perfect next week I'm
making a terrible decision and I'm going
to do a video on Goku blue versus
Superman 1 million uh talk about
dragging out the irrational people out
there uh god that's going to be a bad
choice but we're gonna do it anyway
because
if there's anything I love its nailing
myself to the cross for your amusement
anyway guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end and I will catch you all later
peace
you